Hey guys Julia here for DNews
The tree of life is HUGE.
HUGE.
According to a draft described in the journal
Proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences.
The latest draft of the great tree named over
2.3 million species of animals, plants, fungi,
and bacteria.
Previous versions of the tree of life only
charted about 100,000 species.
But this new HUGE tree is truly an awesome
sight to behold.
To get a close up look at the whole thing
check out https://tree.opentreeoflife.org.
There’s a link in the description.
But that got me wondering, with millions and
millions of species on this planet.
How do we tell them apart?
Evolution is a beautiful thing.
The branches of life spread out in every direction
as life finds a way into every niche imaginable.
A new species arises in a process called speciation.
It’s when something happens to separate
it from all that came before, like a new trait
or geological isolation.
Naturalists like Charles Darwin used to tell
species apart the old fashioned way.
Just by lookin’ at em, which is called morphology.
It’s telling species apart by their appearance.
But there’s another way to define a species,
biologically.
I’ve often heard a species defined as animals
that can reproduce and make a viable, fertile
offspring.
Basically if two animals can make a baby that
lives and can later make it’s own baby,
then those two animals are the same species.
Which is basically what the Biological Species
Concept (BSC) says.
This concept was introduced by biologist Ernst
Mayr in the mid-20th century as "species are
groups of interbreeding natural populations
that are reproductively isolated from other
such groups."
But both of these definitions aren’t perfect.
Life finds a way.
So sometimes creatures that look wildly different
can breed.
Like take dog breeds for example.
If you were an alien taxonomist coming to
Earth for the first time, you might be very
confused by how all these creatures, from
the smallest to chihuahua to the greatest
Dane could possibly be the same breed.
On the other hand a group of animals that
look an awful lot alike can actually be different
species.
In some cases different species evolved similar
traits because they’re in similar environments
like Fossas and cats, which cannot reproduce.
Or different species might be closely related
and look a lot alike but can’t produce fertile
offspring.
Like horses and donkeys.
Sure they can produce a hybrid called a mule,
but they’re sterile.
But even on a finer level, sometimes scientists
get a surprise and find that different species
might not be so different after all.
And that’s just the trouble a group of scientists
in Australia ran into.
In a study published in the journal Biology
Letters researchers found that different species
of Rock-Wallabys were swapping DNA!
Six different species of rockwallaby were
thought to be separate species because the
way their genetic material package would stop
an offspring from being fertile.
But upon genetic analysis the researchers
found gene flow between the species, suggesting
something else was going on, forcing them
to rethink their evolution.
This finding suggests that these animals were
getting it on, making babies that could make
some more babies.
The rock-wallabies might not be “reproductively
isolated”, possibly meaning they were more
like a single species than previously thought.
Like in the case of these rock-wallabies scientists
could see a species’ history written in
its DNA.
Thanks to modern technology, molecular genetic
sequencing changed the game in biology.
By comparing the DNA of different animals,
scientists can see how they’re related or
not.
This was a huge advance in the field of taxonomy.
It’s how we know our closest cousins are
chimps and bonobos, if we went by morphology
alone, perhaps we’d think orangutans were
our next of kin.
According to a study published in the Journal
of Biogeography we share more physical features
with orangutans, like beards on men and similar
shoulder blades.
But molecular genetics revealed we share only
97% of our DNA with them and 99% with chimps
and bonobos.
So it can help us not just learn about the
rest of world, but taxonomy helps us find
our place in the animal kingdom too.
Some people think taxonomy and naming species
is dumb, because it does seem somewhat arbitrary.
I mean humans are the ones deciding where
those lines between species are.
But I think it’s really important.
Because humans need to categorize things to
make sense of this crazy, chaotic world.
and it’s so important to keep track of all
the diversity of life on this planet, while
it’s still here.
There’s a real risk we’re losing species
before we can even find them.
So no, taxonomy isn’t perfect.
But it’s the best we’ve got.
Taxonomy helps us know our history, like when
recently scientists announced the discovery
of yet another human-like ancestor.
So Julian asked the question, how do we determine
if they belong to the genus homo in this great
episode right here.
Alright friends, if you haven’t heard the
news yet, WE’RE DOING A LIVE SHOW.
RIGHT HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO!
I’M SO EXCITED!
We’ve got a great line up of all your favorite
hosts.
I’ll be there, trace will be there Julian,
Amy and Crystal will be there and so so many
more special guests like Dr. Joe Hanson from
It’s Okay to Be Smart and Brian Brushwood,
magician, TV personality, host of Scam School,
Anthropologist Natalia Reagan, and Dr. Carin
Bondar, Discovery Channel host and TED presenter.
It’s all going down October 22.
So grab your tickets before they’re gone.
there’s a link in the description.